i haven't gotten through it yet but i've
been
trying to get to minecomp
and you know throughout his history has
been taken down and up it actually was
taken down from amazon for a while
recently
what can you say about
keeping that stuff up so the reason i'm
it was taken down from amazon i mean
there's there's a large number of people
that will read that
and
um the hate in their heart will grow
so they're not using it for educational
purposes you can't put a plaque on the
mine comp you're ruining minecamp then
like you can't i mean this is you know
amazon can't do a warning saying like um
or expergate you get an expirated
version of minecraft take out the word
you know exactly
exactly
so it still just stands on its own yeah
i mean it's uh
not well written
so you can maybe convince yourself that
it's okay because it's not well written
so it's not it's not like this inspiring
book of ideology that could easily
convince
but uh
can you steal man the argument that my
comp should be banned and can you steal
man the argument that it should be not
banned
well i wouldn't say it should be banned
i think if anything that might make it
forbidden fruit
now this might be
different when we come to statues on the
public square after world war ii
the statues of hitler there must have
been thousands of them were taken down
now i think even the most rabid
um opponents of cancel culture
would not say there was something wrong
with taking down the statues of hitler
that were in every office building every
post office
so
i think a lot depends on the
placement and the purpose of icons of
statues of texas i don't see the harm in
being able to buy mineconf it's so out
of this world
and now by now
just the language and
uh if anything there probably is more
good done by people being shocked at how
dumb it is
and the evil that might be done
by someone reading it i i can't imagine
people being really gripped by that
now partly just because it's
kind of outdated and crazy crazy talk so
in that case i would not be uh in favor
of that
when it comes to monuments or other
types of things
it's a judgment call in each case i
think it has to be probably voted on
but it also uh i think
in many of these cases there's an add-on
view it would fix a lot of the problems
we'll jump around a little bit we'll
come back to uh medicine and uh war on
cancer let me just add one thing on that
recently the
the name of uh macmillan who works on
the charge of the electron in early part
of the 20th century his name was taken
off of
a building at caltech
well
to take his name off what do you really
do it wasn't a central aspect of his
actual work it's not why he was put on
the
name of that building at caltech
and also the memory is lost and the
lesson is lost
when you could have kept the
macmillan name uh on the building and
added a plaque you know this guy was a
racist or this guy was a eugenicist or
some something to make a teaching moment
instead of just a forgetting moment
you